bonsoir les titres le franc très attaqué
aujourd'hui sur les marchés financiers
Édouard Baladur réaffirme qu'il n'y aura
pas de dévaluation accord à lunedic les
partenaires sociaux et le ministère du
travail ont trouvé un moyen de financer
l'assurance chômage mais tout le monde
devra payer nouveau suicide d'un
industriel en Italie raou Gardini
l'ancien patron de la Montedison s'est
tiré une B dans la tête le Tour de
France victoire au sprint aujourd'hui à
Bordeaux d'abdoujaparov indouren va être
sacré ce
weekend c'est par le cyclisme que nous
allons commencer mais pas par le Tour de
France en moins d'une semaine le record
du monde de l'heure est tombé pour la
deuxème fois après laamateur écossais
auri en Norvège dimanche dernier c'est
un champion olympique anglais Chris
bordman qui a couru 52 km 720 dans
l'heure à Bordeaux mzer et auri les
précédents détenteurs des records sont
maintenant loin derrière l frédri B
François priv et dire que cela faisait 9
ans que ce record sommeillait et puis
coup sur coup gr maobri et ce matin
Chris Borman à Bordeaux améliore le
record de l'heure 52 km 270 pour bornman
c'est 674 m de mieux cobri dont le
record n'aura donc duré que 6 jours
j'étais très confiant en ma préparation
quand j'ai vu cobri avait réussi 51 km
500 j'étais heureux pour lui mais je
savais qu'il n'y aurait pas de problème
pour moi en tout c'est plus d'un km qui
été gagné en une semaine plus
intéressante est la comparaison entre
les performances d'obry et de bourman
tous deux viennent de Grande-Bretagne
mais Aury 27 ans est un vrai amateur
alors que bordman 24 ans passera bientôt
professionnel la grande différence c'est
bien sûr la position sur le vélo bordman
à gauche adopte une position classique
de triathlète auri à droite ayant adopté
une extravagante prise aérodynamique qui
selon les avis est un atout ou un danger
le vélo de bourman est français et est
composé d'un cadre monoco le vélo de
Aury est lui doté de roue à bâton et
d'un guidon plat c'est sûr ils sont très
différents mais difficile de dire lequel
est vraiment le meilleur des chiffres
plus précis sont étonnant le vélo de
bordman est incontestablement plus léger
mais aussi beaucoup plus cher quant au
braquet utilisé le 521 d'b reste le plus
impressionnant alors il faut sans doute
se réjouir avant tout de l'opposition de
style que nous ont offerte bordman et
Aury bordman a conquis ce matin sa place
dans l'histoire du cyclisme mais auri a
déjà annoncé qu'il retenterait le record
peut-être en septembre tous les deux
disent en tout cas qu'ils peuvent faire
beaucoup mieux tout comme un certain
miguelinduren ça y est l'assurance
chômage a trouvé un financement après 48
heures de suspense et négociation
difficile partenaires sociaux et
gouvernement se sont mis d'accord sur le
financement de l'Unedic mais tout le
monde devra payer sa côte partart on le
verra vite sur les fiches de paye
Yannick
leranchant négociation nonstop pour un
protocole d'accord tant attendu première
mesure l'augmentation des cotisations
chômage plus 0,9 % au 1er août un bon
tiers à la charge des salariés notamment
les cadres mais la plus grosse partie
sera payée par les entreprises recettes
escomptées 16 milliards de francs
deuxème mesure économiser chaque année 4
milliards 600 millions sur les
allocations chômage celles-ci ne seront
pas augmenté au 1er juillet de plus le
délai de carence lors d'une inscription
à la NPE est porté de 7 à 8 jours
l'accord de ce matin a été signé sous
les auspices du ministre du Travail qui
entendait aiguillonner les partenaires
sociaux en montrant l'exemple l'état
versera 10 milliards de francs par an
dans les caisses de l'assurant chômage
pour le patronnat et quatre syndicats
sur 5 il s'agit d'un accord de crise
pour limiter les dégâts c'est un accord
courageux courageux parce que nous avons
su montrer notre
détermination à ne pas toucher aux
durées des allocations ni au montant des
allocations pour les chômeurs il est bon
parce que nous avons sauvé sauvé le
système de protection chômage il est bon
parce que nous avons fait la preu que
les partenaires sociaux étai capabl de
de prendre leur responsabilité et du
côté des employeurs nous avons pris nos
responsabilité mais pour la CGT pas de
politique du moindre mal l'accord de ce
matin est injuste dans le dispositif
arrêé si l'État intervient à hauteur de
10 milliards les entreprises pour un peu
moins de 10 milliards les chômeurs et
les salariés vont payer une part aussi
importante normalement cet accord règle
les problèmes deun pour 3 an d'une
nouvelle explosion du
chômage à propos d'emploi cette
expérience à rue mal maison elle ne
touche pas directement le chômage parce
que elle s'adresse tout de même à des
jeunes qui font des études il s'agit de
préparer les jeunes au monde du travail
Pascal
golomer le geste n'est pas très assuré
mais la conscience professionnelle est
bien là ils n'ont pas encore 17 ans et
ils sont déjà au travail en pleine été
20h dans la semaine à repeindre les
barrières du stade c'est la mairie qui
les emploie et qui les paye 500 francs
par semaine si Auris pas l'argent je ser
pas j'ai besoin d'argent pour partir en
vacances je des affes pour payer ma
ligne de téléphone et c'est pas trop
contraignant de se lever tous les matins
pour venir travailler comme ça en plein
mois de juillet un peu je un peu
7h30 attention ça petit boulot peut-être
la municipalité préfère parler de
mission d'intérêt général une centaine
au total dans ses différents
rép durant tout l'été d'abord pour
initier les jeunes à l'emploi et à ses
contraintes un jour ou l'autre il vont
bientôt avoir 18 ansêtre obligé chercher
du travail
et d'aller voir les patrons de rendre
visite sur les lieux c'est toujours
quelque chose à prendre une mainœuvre
bon marché la mairie répond qu'il ne
s'agit que d'une expérience limitée à 2
mois sans conséquence sur le marché de
l'emploi avec pour seul objectif de
faciliter l'insertion il y a des jeunes
qui sont pas capable aujourd'hui de
rentrer dans un circuit de formation ou
d'emploi est-ce que c'est pas le moment
de prendre aussi des mesures le plus tôt
possible c'est exactement comme la lutte
contre l'échec scolaire est-ce qu'il
faut attendre qu'un jeune soit dans la
merde pour commencer à essayer de faire
qu' n'y soit pas bah nous on pense
exactement l'verse une bonne opération
en tout cas pour l'image sociale de la
ville opération h la loi pour l'instant
puisque la mairie ne veut pas payer ses
charges patronales espère en voir sa
mesure reprise au niveau national avec
exonération à la
clé
le franc durement attaqué sur les
marchés financiers aujourd'hui mais la
réplique a été immédiate d'une part les
autorités monétaires ont pris des
mesures sérieuse pour résister et puis
d'autre part Douard Baladur a dit très
clairement il était en voyage en Tunisie
il a dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de
d'évaluation il est en voyage au Maroc
pardon Éric
Monier il y a eu septembre dernier puis
janvier voilà maintenant la crise de
juillet de la vie de tous les experts la
pire depuis quelques jours la monnaie
française est devenue une pestiférie
plus personne n'en veut la Banque de
France et la bundesban ont beau tenté de
lui maintenir la tête hors de l'eau en
en achetant massivement rien n'y fait le
franc coule ce matin les deux banques
centrales ont tenté une nouvelle fois de
rassurer en publiant un communiqué
commun et la Banque de France jusqu'ici
cantonné dans une stratégie de Rost
graduée a sorti l'artillerie lourde en
augmentant l'un de ses tau directeurs
but de la contreoffensive rendre la
spéculation plus coûteuse pour les
spéculateurs alors aujourd'hui deux
questions se posent d'abord pourquoi
cette nouvelle poussée de fièvre elle
traduit la crise de doute que traversent
les financiers quant à la capacité ou à
la volonté des gouvernements européens
de construire l'Union économique et
monétaire deè question comment en sortir
quitter le serpent monétaire dévaluer
exclu dit le gouvernement le salut
serait une nouvelle baisse des tau
allemands mais l'Allemagne toujours
reprise à des tendances inflationnistes
hésitera même par solidarité à faire un
tel
geste de chiffres encore retenir les
prix à la consommation ont enregistré
une baisse en France en juin par rapport
à mai 0,1 % c'est une confirmation de
l'INC et puis autres chiffres pendant le
même mois la consommation des ménages a
augmenté de 4,5 % ça c'est un petit
signe de reprise sérieuse affrontement
la nuit dernière à Bordeaux entre
agriculteurs et policiers les
agriculteurs voulaient protester contre
les importations de fruits et légumes il
y a eu des blessés François
priva il est 23h hier soir à Bordeaux
lorsque 300 agriculteur de la
Coordination Rurale pénètre de force
dans l'enceinte du marché d'intérêt
national avec pour but de détruire tout
fruits ou légumes d'importation la
riposte des gardes mobile est immédiate
en moins d'une dizaine de minutes les
agriculteurs sont repoussés à 500 m du
bâtiment dans l'affrontement deux gardes
mobiles trois agriculteurs et un
journaliste sont
blessés les manifestants choisissent
alors d'intercepter les camions de
livraison qui se rendent marché
plusieurs centaines de kilos de fruits
et légumes en provenance d'Espagne du
Chili et d'Afrique du Nord sont déversés
sur la
chaussée et aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut
c'est que les pouvoirs publics utilisent
la closeuse de sauvegarde pour nous
protéger donc des importations massives
de ces produits effectivement on peut
remarquer des des des kiwi importés du
Chili encore actuellement alors que les
2 tiers de la production nationale ont
été détru jusqu'à ce jour c'est très
grave à 0h30 les agriculteurs battent en
retraite annonçant de nouvelles actions
pour les semaines à venir les pêcheurs
eux adoptent la tactique inverse c'est
une opération séduction qu'ils ont
décidé de mener sur les côtes de France
tout l'été pour vanter les mérites du
poisson il paraît qu'un Français sur qu
n'en mange jamais la caravane était à
Marseille hier Patrice Velet Dominique
Bonet sardine sur le vieux port allez
queer le poisson de Marseille la RAS
casse la RAS casse c'est la brouille à
baisse non à part ceux qui sont vraiment
habitués autrement il connaissent
pas ils sont vraiment pas informés alors
pour tout savoir suivez le ton celui de
la caravane du poisson une visite en
pleine mer du chalutage à la recette de
cuisine du bar au Merlan ou comment tout
savoir sur l'un des derniers vrais
produits sauvages encore en vente on
vient du centre on est de depis dô alors
on n pas l'occasion de voir tout ça la
vie des pêcheurs on connaît les poissons
mais enfin surtout dans l'assiette ça
correspond bien à la vie des pêcheurs et
c'est vrai que c'est très difficile
aussi hein ils ont beaucoup de mérite un
événement sur le vieux port l'occasion
de parler habitude alimentaire au Japon
60 kg de poisson par habitant et par an
en France moins de 10 c'est un métier
traditionnel c'est un métier en voie
disparition donc d'autant plus des des
choses qu'il faut qu'il faut expliquer
aux gens dans chaque port les pêcheurs
locaux sont associés à l'opération c'est
bon pour l'image de marque donc pour le
commerce mais je pense que ça va leur
permettre de de connaître autre chose
que ce qu'ils connaissent eux quoi sorti
du merlang et du poisson boui ça pourra
peut-être leur faire connaître notre
goût au goût comme à l'odeur la sardine
c'est la meilleure elle s'est dégusté
toute la journée d'hier il parait même
qu'elle ne bouge plus le vieux
port ceci encore Virgine condamnée
condamnée à fermer son magasin des
Champs-Élysées le dimanche sinon Virgine
devra payer 250000 francs par jour
d'ouverture en
infraction un véritable coup de tonner
en Italie ce matin 3 jours après un
deuxème industriel d'envergure s'est
suicidé après Gabriel cari c'est cette
fois raou Gardini qui s'est tiré une
balle dans la tête il allait être arrêté
aujourd'hui pour une affaire de
corruption il avait été le patron du
groupe ferouzi Montedison Raoul Gardini
c'était un condotiéré de l'industrie
c'était aussi un passionné de voile il
s'était fait connaître du monde entier
en finançant le bateau italien Il Moro
d' Venezia qui était parvenu V l'année
dernière en finale de la Coupe de
l'América Jean-Pierre mtivé
portrait le Palacio d'ario propriété à
Venise de Raoul Gardini racheté
disait-il pour une bouchée de pain car
pour les Vénitiens cette maison porte
malheur plusieurs de ces anciens
propriétaires sont décédés de mort
violente c'est aussi dans ces images de
Venise que les Français connaissaient le
mieux Raoul Gardini lorsqu'il se lance à
la conquête de la coupe América en 92
avec son voilier ilmoro des ventia qui
terminera
un fou de voile RA Gardini il finance
catamaran d'Olivier Deon le Charal pour
sa tentative de tour du monde en 80
jours l'opération me en mer elle
paraissait loin voici comment RA Gardini
jug la situation italienne au début
deé c'est la liberté qui arrive
aujourd'hui les Italiens rest rest là
pour se moderniser il sont en train de
le faire je crois qu'ils sont en train
de le faire bien 2 mois plus tard la
justice italienne le rattrape et enquête
sur sa gestion dans la mont Edison il y
était en affaire avec Gabriele kagriari
qui s'est lui-même suicidé dans sa
cellule voici 2 jours Raoul Gardini on
l'appelait le paysan à cause de ses
origines l'entreprise de sa belle
famille ferouzi il en avait fait une
multinationale rachetant en France les
huiles leciieur et le sucre bégincet et
en Italie le géant de la chimie
Montedison en 91 brouille avec les
ferouzi il est limogé avec 2 milliards
de francs il investit en France avec son
allié le banquier et Jean-Marc Bern il
s'intéressait beaucoup diton au futures
privatisation question pour l'Italie
après le suicide d'un de ses plus grands
industriel la chasse aux sorcières
a-t-elle atteint un niveau inacceptable
en ce moment en effet l'Italie est
saisie par une frénésie d'arrestation
pour la lutte antiorruption Gérard
beaufice à Rome pour les valeurs de
poule comme pour les délinquants en
colleblanc qui ont détourné parfois par
habitude des milliards de lires ou des
millions de dollars la loi italienne est
la même certains ne le supp porte pas il
tombe d'un piédestal d'autres savent à
quoi ils s'exposent la réforme du code
de procédure pénale en 1989 a donner au
juges le pouvoir de recourir
systématiquement à la détention
préventive ils ne s'en sont pas privés
et sous le prétexte d'empêcher la
disparition des preuves et les pressions
sur les
témoins l'exception et non la règle il
faut bien constater que l'esprit de la
loi n'a pas été respecté mais plutôt
appliqué à la lettre même si les juges
main propres souitent faire très
honnêtement leur travail avec parfois un
peu de Z et quelques
débordement on peut croire que les
magistrat vont trop loin même au-delà de
leurs
compétences de mon point de vue je crois
qu'il font un travail honnête en plein
respect de la loi cependant quelquesuns
pourrai sans doute changer leur
comportement peut-être dans ce travail
quelques dérives se produisent des
bavures pourrait d'ailleurs retrouver
dans tous les métiers tous les hommes
peuvent se
trom c'est peut-être en général du côté
de la marche de la justice et de sa
lenteur légendaire qu'il faut regarder
pour comprendre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en Italie sans oublier bien
sûr les conditions de détention derrière
les barreaux des prisons
transalpines en France pour l'heure la
plus grosse affaire de corruption
présumée c'est celle du match au m
valencienne déclaration de Jean-Pierre
bernes tout à l'heure sur Radio montcles
la peau de tapis on ne l'aura jamais par
bernes dit le directeur de l'OM qui
réaffirme par ailleurs qu'à travers lui
c'est bien tapis qu'on veut abattre je
vous rappelle qu'hier monsieur bernes a
été remise en liberté sous contrôle
judiciaire Benoît gadré les
suites Jean-Pierre bernes a-t-il le
droit de rencontrer Bernard tapi la
question se pose alors que les deux
hommes après avoir atterris hier soir à
Toulon navigue en ce moment même sur la
Méditerranée Jean-Pierre bernes est
libre mais il est placé sous comp ô
judiciaire l'arrêt de la chambre
d'accusation stipule qu'il ne peut
rencontrer des personnes mises en examen
et des témoins entendu dans le cadre de
l'information pour corruption or Bernard
tapi a été entendu comme témoin par le
juge dans l'affaire Primorac une affaire
connexe au dossier de corruption mais
liée juridiquement à la même information
judiciaire l'arrêt est donc ambigu et a
donné lieu aujourd'hui à toutes sortes
d'interprétation à la cour d'appel de
Douet on Pr prcise ce soir qu'il n'était
pas dans l'intention des magistrats
d'interdire à Monsieur bernes de voir
Bernard tapis en dépit des protestations
de certains avocats des joueurs mis en
examen il semble que le directeur
général de l'OM soit dans son bon droit
d'autant que l'arrêt ne lui a pas été
encore notifié quoi qu'il en soit le
juge beffi poursuit ses investigations
plusieurs auditions sont prévues la
semaine prochaine à Valencienne dont
celle de l'ex-entraîneur du club Borau
Primorac voilà la précision apportée par
le parquet à l'instant même cette
dépêche me la prend l'arrêt de la
chambre d'accusation de la cour de Doué
remettant Jean-Pierre bernè en liberté
donc lui interdit de rencontrer Bernard
tapi mais cette interdiction n'entrera
en vigueur que la semaine prochaine donc
pour l'instant il a bien le droit de
rencontrer Bernard tapi à propos de
cette affaire France 3 porte plainte
contre Bernard tapi hier le patron de
l'OM n'a pas hésité à jeter par-dessus
bord la caméra de nos confrères de
France 3 Méditerranée drôle de me
écoutez le témoignage de George
materra nous étions à une vingtaine de
mètres du bateau de berartapis avec le
caméraman et puis le skippper du bateau
nous avions essayé de le contacter par
téléphone il n'a pas souhaité nous
répondre et au moment où nous repartions
nous avons vu son annexe se diriger vers
nous c'est lui qui pilotait avec son
attaché parlementaire Marc Fratani
Berard tapis est monté à bord et sans
aucune sommation il a pris la caméra il
l'a jeté à la mer en disant que Ben les
images maintenant étaient à l'eau cétait
réglé et puis il est reparti
aussitôt le syndicat des journalistes le
SNJ a décidé ce soir de se porter partie
civile dans cette affaire donc à propos
de France I et Bernard tapi l'actualité
internationale avec les Anglais et
l'Europe le traité de Maastrich est
quasiment adopté par les Britanniques il
reste encore quelques confirmations de
procédure mais le plus gros a été fait
par John medor le Premier ministre qui a
mis sa démission en jeu c'est la fin
d'une lutte de près d'un an entre le
Premier ministre britannique et députés
conservateur de son propre parti
anti-européen Philippe haroir à
Londres pour la confiance 339 contre
299 finalement John Major s'en tire bien
mais il a eu chaud hier soir il était
défait par 23 débutés conservateurs
rebelles farouchement anti-européens qui
n'ont pas hésité à s'allier à
l'opposition travailliste pour bloquer
le traité de mastrich et mettre en
difficulté le Premier ministre John
Major a tapé du point sur la table en
posant la question de confiance où vous
m'approuvez et le traiter avec ou ce
sont des élections générales anticipé
que les conservateurs sont sûrs de
perdre argument imparable les rebelles
ont baissé pavillon Sir Leon Britton
commissaire européen venu en connaisseur
respire le traité de mastrich pourra
être ratifié après un dernier obstacle
juridique dans le camp conservateur
parmi les antimmastrich reste un goût
amer si on avait eu un référendum comme
en France toutes cette questions auraiit
pu éêté décidé très longtemps et
maintenant il va falloir recoller les
morceaux John Major sort affaibli et
humilié de l'épreuve le Parti
conservateur est divisé l'image du
Premier ministre est mauvaise dans le
pays 15 % seulement des Britanniques lui
font confiance pour remonter la pente ce
ne sera pas facile Édouard Baladur le
Premier ministre français était au Maroc
je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure au
programme du voyage la coopération
économique entre les deux pays et
notamment les rapports du du Maroc et de
l'Europe Gill Rabine André
sor avant d'être reçu par Hassan 2
Édouard Baladur sétait recueilli sur le
tombeau de Mohamed V le père du
roi dépôt de gerbe visite de la mosquée
arrêt sur le site de ce qui était au 13e
siècle la plus grande mosquée du monde
mais question de style Édouard Baladur a
consacré malgré tout l'essentiel de sa
journée de voyage officielle à Raba au
travail aux entretiens il s'agissait de
faire comprendre et accepter les
nouvelles mesures prises à Paris sur
l'immigration en proposant au marocains
de les aider à mieux contrôler leurs
émigrants la meilleure façon de les
aider c'est d'acheter leur production et
de leur vendre la nôtre et en même temps
il ne faut pas qu'à la faveur de la
différence des régimes sociaux et
économiques cela conduise à une
destruction d'emploi chez nous en
France Monsieur Baladur était aussi venu
penser de vieille PL le roi du Maroc n'a
toujours pas oublié les interventions de
Madame Danielle mitteran en faveur des
réfugiés saraou ou d'Abraham Sarfati
l'opposant marocain d'extrême gauche
c'était pourtant il y a 2 ans ceci
encore cette information terrible en
provenance du Brésil en une seule nuit
hier les escadrons de la mort auraient
tué 25 enfants dans les rues de Rio de
janeero il faut savoir qu'à Rio et dans
d'autres villes du Brésil les enfants
pauvres des rues sont considérés comme
des nuisances et supprimé par des tueurs
professionnels lors d'opération
d'extermination retour à la France avec
les départs ce weekend attention la
circulation sera chargée un petit peu
partout en France et soyez très très
prudents d'ailleurs les Français le sont
de plus en plus prudents et les
accidents sont moins nombreux Patrice
pely
748 tu de moins soit une baisse de 8 %
par rapport à l'année dernière jamais
depuis 73 la baisse des accidents sur
les routes de France n'avait été aussi
importante en 73 on avait déjà senti une
amélioration grâce à trois mesures le
port de la ceinture obligatoire la
limitation de vitesse et les premières
lois sur l'alcool au volant des mesures
qui au fil des années ont été
renforcé depuis 3 ans on a eu de grandes
mesures on a eu le contrôle technique on
a eu le port obligatoire de la ceinture
à l'arrière et en clé de wû
naturellement l'an dernier le permis à
point qui a permis également d'améliorer
considérablement les choses les chiffres
s'améliorent mais reste important en 92
9000 personnes ont trouvé la mort sur la
route 25 tué par jour les mêmes périodes
critiques reviennent chaque
année on constate tous les ans que les
weekends de juillet et celui de
juilletaot où on arrive sont les deux
weekends les plus dangereux de l'année
c'est pas la toussin c'est pas la
pente-côte c'est jamais cela c'est
toujours les weekend de juillet
également le mois de juillet et de loin
celui a le plus d'accidents et le plus
tués suivi par le mois d'août donc il
faut faire très attention et puis dans
la mesure du possible n'hésitez plus à
emprunter les autoroutes les grands axes
grâce à leur voies séparées et à leur
meilleure visibilité s'avère quatre fois
plus sûr que les routes
nationales coup double pour les douanes
européennes deux grosses prises de
drogue presque simultanément 400 kg de
cocaïne saisie à Perpignan dans Les
pyénées Orientales et puis une prise à
peu près équivalente au large des
Pays-Bas Valérie
Gaget en montant à l'arrière du camion
italien les chiens des douines ont
immédiatement flairer ses cartons à
l'intérieur les douaniers ont découvert
plusieurs paquets de 1 à 2 kg de poudre
de cocaïne mais l'essentiel de la
cargaison était ailleurs habilement
caché sous le plancher du véhicule au
total 406 kg de drogue pur à 90 % ont
été saisis valeur estimée à la revente
plus de 400 millions de francs
l'opération est presque le fruit du
hasard seuls deux anomalies avaient
intrigué les douaniers le service a eu
son attention attiré par la présence
d'un camion qui ne disposait pas de
tachigraphe et qui n'a pas pu présenter
ses documents commerciaux le camion a
été déclaré vide mais il aurait dû
pouvoir présenter des des documents
commerciaux relativ à son lieu de
livraison ou au lieu où il allait
changer des
marchandises au Pays-Bas ce sont les
gardes de-côte qui ont tu du nez en
pointant leur projecteur sur ce Zodiaque
qui tentaiit d'accoster discrètement sur
une plage le petit Canau piloté par deux
Américains était aussi chargé que le
camion italien arrêté en France 400 kg
de cocaïne la même prise à 6 kg
près le sport weekend vraisemblablement
triomphal dans le Tour de France pour
miguelindouren il est en tête et il ne
reste que deux étapes dont une contre la
montre demain le contre la monte c'est
sa spécialité aujourd'hui à Bordeaux
victoire du Sprinter Abdou jaaparov
Christophe
Duchiron scène quotidienne de la vie du
Ploton rendant pinsc dit Pinpin à crevé
on change de roue mais au lieu de le
remettre en scelle le mécanicien va
mettre Pinin dans le fossé en effet il y
a de quoi rire et attention pour
l'arrière
dossard 169 l'italien Santa
Romita il n'y a pas de quoi rire chute
heureusement sans
gravité détendu et tranquille c'est
migeline duen dans le peloton qui roule
àure
modéré devant c'est beaucoup plus
nerveux dans ce groupe d'échappé qui
compte 21 coureurs il y a la TR français
durant Simon et Charlie mot il y a là
aussi l'beek au maillot vert
abdar
ensemble dans les rues de Bordeaux c'est
au sprint que va se jouer la victoire
c'est en forceabouparov remporte sa deè
étape les Français font ce qu'ils
peuvent mais ils ont encore manqué leur
coup je crois que toute la première
partie du tour ils sont malheureusement
pass à l'attaque mais un peu désordonné
tout le monde voulait vraiment se
montrer puis malheureusement ça n'a pas
fait de victoire d'étape je crois que
Pascal l nous a soulagé quand même un
petit peu mais je pense pas qu'on a fait
un très très mauvais tour de France
derriè les échapp Leon est arrivé 4
minutes 52 pas de changement au général
chez les premiers demain un contre la
montre individuelle de 48 km qui devrait
ravir migaline
duay en tennis belle performance des
françaises dans la Coupe de la
Fédération qui est l'équivalent de la
Coupe dvis pour les femmes les
Françaises natthalie tosia et Julie hard
se sont qualifiés pour les demi-finales
en battant les Tchèques notamment
Nathalie tosia pardon qui a battu Yana
Novotna la finaliste de
Wimbledon en football côté sport la
saison commence ce soir en match avant
sénante Monaco demain soir ce seront
tous les autres matchs présentation de
la saison par Yan Lavoie les favoris les
outsiders les transfert les surprises
même l'OM a préparé la saison dans un
climat détestable le club va devoir
maintenant faire front sur le terrain
heureusement Marc bourriier le nouvel
entraîneur marseillais arrivé dans la
tempête a su déclencher le plan hor sec
compte tenu des des troubles que nous
avons un peu subi lors de notre arrivée
à fondromeux les garçons ont réussi à
faire le vide à penser surtout football
à partir du moment où il mettait le pied
sur sur le terrain je suis même sûr que
ça se passe très bien parmi les bisus
Marseillais il y a les exocerrois
prunier du tuel mais aussi Rousset fugi
Henri foutr et le retour de stoskovic
c'est nouveau ajouté aux anciens forme
sur le papier une équipe qui a toutes
les chances de rééditer une grande
saison en fait tout dépendra des
conclusions de l'affaire de Valencienne
les joueurs resteraient-ils motivés
s'ils apprenaient en cours de saison
qu'ils sont destinés à descendre en
division
2 à Monaco ruibaros a cédé sa Enzo chifo
qui a posé son sac pour la troisème fois
en France il a dit au revoir au Torino
et à l'Italie après Bordeaux et osser
Enzo a de nouveau craqué pour notre
championnat son association avec linsman
un autre déçu du calcho devrait résoudre
tous les problèmes d'efficacité du club
monégasque mais la saison 93-94 pourrait
bien être celle du PSG Cobos Borell et
gravelen qui a étraîné le nouveau
maillot du PSG sont les nouvelles
recrues à Paris on attend plus que le
Brésilien raï meilleur joueur
sud-américain l'an passé avec Sao Polo
il sera l'une des attractions de notre
championn
ils sont nombreux les challengers Nantes
osser Bordeaux et pourquoi pas
Saint-Étienne qui a su séduire Laurent
Blanc il a quitté nî sans regret pour
rejoindre Jean-Michel Larquet à
Saint-Étienne
Tigana lui a pris en main l'Olympique
Lyonnais et il a su convaincre trois
champions d'Europe marseillais P Olmeta
et Amoros Lyon a des
prétentions pour can ang martig un seul
objectif le maintien pour se faire ces
trois clubs n'ont pas recruté de star
mais des joueurs expérimentés solides
comme Péant Bruno Germain à ang bouquet
Pagal andiani à
martig allez la saison peut maintenant
débuter mais avant ballon mon beau
ballon peu importe qui sera champion
dis-nous simplement que tu vivras de
passion et non de
corruption la tournée festival direction
montigac ce soir qui organise chaque
année un festival de folklore en vux d'ê
cette année un instrument très ancien la
vielle Sophie Guillou Laurent
lejop assoupi tout contre sa rivière la
pacifique petite ville de Montignac
murmure son inquiétude on annonce pour
l'après-midi un attentat sonore les
terroristes agissent en plein jour avec
des lunettes pour seul camouflage leur
armes s'actionnent à la manivelle et
bombardent les passants de sonorités
étranges le commando signe tous ces
actes d'un nom barbare le viéistique
Orchestra car la cause qu'il défend
c'est celle de la viel rou une vénérable
ancêtre de 1000 ans d'âge relégué
aujourd'hui au rang de curiosité
folklorique et pourtant revampée par ses
joyeux iconoclastes elle se dévergonne
pour offrir une pleine d'insolite et
d'insolence les tenants de la tradition
en reste
quoi c'est un instrument fascinant enfin
c'est personnel hein première fois que
j'ai vu ça je me suis dit bon je suis
resté cloué quoi devant et puis cloué et
puis après quand on en joue c'est
physique c'est un instrument qui résonne
vraiment dans le corps c'est primaire
presque c'est
c'est très sensitif quoi alors je crois
que c'est avant tout ça
l'argument un argument pour se faire
plaisir à la mode arabo andalouse ou en
improvisation jazz le viéistique
Orchestra ne se refuse aucune
audace d'un son venu du fond des âges
les 14ici de l'orchestre tirent une
partition inédite qui fait de la viel
rou un instrument du futur alors
rendez-vous dans 1000
ans voilà la fin de cette édition dans
un instant laurore mchco pour une Méo
une météo très orageux ce weekend avec
des orages forts faites attention
dernière édition du journal ce sera
Philippe lefet vers 23h40 et demain dès
le journal de 13h vous retrouverez votre
petit chouchou Bruno Mazure dinono bonne
soirée sur France